My name is Joshua Jean Baptiste.
I'm 24 years old.
I'm a born and raised Miami resident.
I'm Haitian-American.
I'm an actor, rapper, recent writer, overall artist.
I love Miami.
I don't plan on going anywhere for quite some time.
I think it's a bubbling pot of potential.
So I have to say that my biggest goal is to be successful with positivity and not negativity.
It's cheesy as it sounds.
I always had an interest in rap when I was younger.
I did poetry as well, so words were always something that I was rather expressive with.
...and "8 Mile" kinda sealed the deal for me.
I was actually like one of the best rappers in my school.
I'd walk down the halls and be high-fived.
I'm trying to grow my own signature style.
The educated hip-hop star now is kind of coming into the limelight.
I like the juxtaposition of professionalism and hood.
I do wear gold chains 'cause I do think it's awesome.
However, I will wear a gold chain with a cardigan.